welcome to this video playing shake
comic let's see ya there two nights
really go 95 know yeah Castle this is
surprisingly popular and just blundering
stuff why would 95 interesting yeah
blundering it is the advantage like it's
already in good shape here with the two
bishops for nothing let's see go back do
I go see five probably this first and
then see five like to open the position
of course c5 take special chicks
yeah but I still want to play that not
quite sure takes takes Knight b5 might
be might be something
ok
so I am came in Bishop easy was plain I
day for what tried everything yep that's
what he wants okay so Bishop c4 is an
idea on 95 ok let's start with 95 maybe
Bishop f5 trying to worsen the structure
there I can also try to save my bishop
here I can try that it's not not
entirely clear but I can try
this night now is unprotected
so v6 was my idea is this on or not
think I can go to e4 though I also have
c6 of course yeah maybe c6 bit simpler
all rights too difficult to get anything
substantial him out of this trying to
keep my head my bishop bear
Bishop f5 yeah okay that time will be a
lil bit tricky you have to be somewhat
somewhat faster b6 what is he doing then
going to be 70 maybe maybe that's
possible night b7 looks a bit crazy but
might be possible
I be some luctus m95 rook takes b7 Roxy
6s Bishop e6 now and I don't believe in
that probably is just going back and
shuffle around like he did the whole
game just try to be quick and do not
nothing much more okay let's preserve
that ok yeah very difficult still to get
something serious m57 95
like you not sure if that works Knight
c3 ok let's take down might might have
nights it's 6am it doesn't doesn't go
for that getting this piece back with c5
yeah it's not really the idea that kind
of outcome from that
yeah the opening is something that you
really want to refute which I did not
manage
maybe I can do something in the end game
after all he takes the Fiji Islands
that's very nice no time morning or even
money a minute but a minute should be
actually enough yet to win this thing it
is pretty bad fam
I shoulda played h5 and stupid that was
stupid I should have played h5 them
that's the problem with the time hammer
time situation now dang it i really
wanted to win this game just have to
play a try fi it forwards even the total
howler this is just a totally bad move
ok go age 58 he resigns it's very stupid
ah
now we have I have two wrong the wrong
bishop there that's the problem
now that sounds really heartbreaking
only only drawing this end game I just
have to play age five and then it's over
H voice is even really really bad yeah
he puts another pawn on a dark square
check Gras offered gain drag character
it should be shot for this just have to
be but yeah I was kind of almost pre
moving that and I just have to play h5
and this thing is completely out
completely over ah yeah then then the
King side is fixed and he put something
more on dark squares and now this is
just an automatic win and probably just
need 20 seconds to do that something
like that get get this free porn now i
don't know i shouldn't blunder b-form
shouldn't protect that I know something
like this ultimately I how do we win
this actually now be three I guess the
egg stakes now this is check winning for
real so this this and he's he's running
out of out of moves to defend all this
misplaced pawns ah now these are the
kind of games that hurt I really heard
he played basically on time from move
one now just dashed out stuff giving me
two bishops for nothing but it was kind
of tricky to play I preserved the
bishops all of the time but he was still
kind of active so it wasn't it wasn't
completely easy does this was
interesting there but probably not
sufficient yeah
okay yeah this is n gamers is ok but
it's nothing nothing super great like
it's better but he shouldn't you
shouldn't probably lose but of course he
does lose after taking every route takes
his seven it's just terrible yeah he has
to keep the rook down and then yeah and
then go from there and look be two or
something c7 just loses especially in
combination with age for it is lost I
think anyway but h5 h4 is especially bad
I just have to play h5 and that's it and
maybe here here g6 is also better of
course I have to I have to him and I was
so annoyed them I have to keep F pawns
on the board that might still win it
might still win actually think about it
I can go to be six probably still win
this I'm here here here but how exactly
do you win big yeah that is probably
enough to make steaks and if he goes
there I can take a check and wins yeah
there's probably still a win I just need
F pawns so that it's not this dreaded
wrong color to corner bishop ok thanks
for watching